see our problem is we don't really know
how to stop
we've got something started and we see
it's going in the wrong direction
and i think the difficulty is to borrow
an old chinese saying
when the wrong man uses the right means
the right means work in the wrong way
in other words there's something wrong
with the way we think
and while that is there everything we do
will be a mess
now what is it that's wrong now as far
as i can see
the basic mistake is that we've invented
this wonderful system
of language and calculation
and that it is at once too simple to
deal with the complexity of the world
and also we are liable to confuse that
system of symbols
with the world itself just as we confuse
say money with wealth
a lot of people are in business to make
money instead of wealth
when they make the money they don't know
what to do with it and so in the same
way
we confuse happiness with status
and we confuse ourselves as living
organisms which are one with this whole
universe
with something we call our personality
now what is our personality
our personality is what we call our
image
our image of ourselves and also our
thought about
ourselves our idea of ourselves this is
the person
in other words what people meet and
understand
and what i understand as alan watts is a
big act
which is not really me because in the
image of alan watts
there are not all my unconscious
processes both psychological and
physical
the construction of my brain is not
contained in the concept
alan watts and the concept alan watts
does not contain
the inseparable relationships which i
have with all the rest of the universe
and therefore that concept is a fraud
and when it's mistaken for the real me
there's a confusion
because if somebody says to be alan
watts do something about it
the concept alan watts can't do anything
in other words because it's only a
concept
you can't make it lift a weight just as
three
as a concept three the number you can't
make just plain three do anything
so also you can't wrap up parcels with
the equator it's a useful imaginary line
but it can't do anything
but we all feel that this concept of
ourselves which we call our personality
or our ego
can do something because we think it
really exists and i'll tell you why we
think it exists
what happens when you if i were to say
to you now look hard at the television
screen
really look at it what do you do
as distinct from just watching it in the
ordinary way when you say now i really
gotta see that what do you do
notice that you tighten muscles all
around here
that you frown a little you clench your
teeth perhaps
now what has that got to do with seeing
anything clearly
absolutely nothing to do with it same
thing when you listen carefully now
listen
catch everything that said will you
start tightening up around your ears
that has nothing to do with hearing
clearly
now from the moment we were little
children when teachers in class screamed
at us pay attention
we go tight in various ways
either to see or hear more clearly to
concentrate
or to will something which is supposed
to be difficult to do
and that constitutes a habitual tension
over the whole body
that's there almost all the time and
that feeling of unnecessary tension
is as it were the material sensation
upon which we fasten this concept of i
we hang it on to that feeling the
concept is not
us the feeling of tension is completely
phony
it has nothing to do with success in
seeing hearing or acting
and so we get the marriage of an
illusion with a falsehood
and that we call ourselves no wonder we
feel cut off from everything alienated
frightened of life and death
so what has to happen is we have to come
back
to a saying
view of our own life
which is the way we really are
an organism functioning in terms of the
whole environment with the whole
environment
instead of this funny little separate
personality but how are we going to do
that
people say you can't change human nature
overnight
you're asking us to give up the ego and
that's the most difficult of all things
to do
actually it isn't because the ego
doesn't exist
but of course if you try to give up your
ego with your ego
then it will take you to the end of time
because this is the point you can't
transform yourself
you can't make yourself sane you can't
make yourself loving
you can't make yourself unselfish
and yet it's absolutely necessary that
we be that way
it's absolutely necessary
if we are going to hand over
the direction of nature to nature which
is what it comes to
it's absolutely necessary that we let go
of ourselves and it can't be done
not by anything that we call doing it
acting
willing or even just accepting things
you can't do it
why because you don't really exist
as that kind of a separate ego or
personality it's just an idea
based on a phony feeling
so when it comes down to it
it's shocking news for us
for the human race for our pride
you're only making a mess by trying to
put things straight
you're trying to straighten out a wiggly
world and no wonder you're in trouble
so you can't do anything so you can't
transform yourself
and what can you do what happens then if
you actually realize you've come to a
dead end
and the human race has come to a dead
end in my opinion
what then commit suicide
or is there something else what happens
when you just wait there's nothing you
can do
you watch
and all you see is what goes on that is
happening of itself
your breathing the wind is blowing
the trees are waving your blood is
circulating
your nerves are tingling it's all going
on itself
but you know that's you that's the real
you the you that goes on of itself
it's not the symbol
it's not the person it's
you that's happening as when you breathe
yes you can get the feeling that i
am breathing by shoving your breath but
your breath goes on
day in and day out without you doing
anything about it or even thinking of it
the same way your brain is functioning
without your forcing it
so when you come to a dead end and we
are individually and socially
now at a dead end
this is the moment of which it is said
man's extremity is god's
opportunity
because we have to stop and when we stop
we find a world that is happening
rather than being done being shoved
and that happening as distinct from
doing
is our fundamental self and our
fundamental self is not something just
inside the skin
it's everything around us with which we
connect
when you look out of your eyes at
nature happening out there you're
looking at you
i'm not going to say what we should do
from then on
but simply that before we think of doing
anything
in this critical situation
we realize the completely illusory
nature of the beings that we think we
are
and get back again to the beings that we
really
are which includes
all this
outside world no longer left outside
you